i think it's because you're approaching
this as though you think bill de blasio
shares the same values you do you think
he cares about people you think he cares
about kids you think he cares about the
homeless
i don't think he does that's his job i
think absolutely it is
but i think he's just he cares about
himself he cares about ideology he cares
about
enriching his family you look at his
wife what did she get a two million
dollar staff budget
when the city is being shut down and
people are losing their jobs his wife's
got a staff
total like two million dollars a year
she what does she have like an artist or
something someone like paints for her
yeah that this is this is what it this
is like it's it's
what kind of government is it what do
you call it is it when you've got the
rich people
by the way hypocrisy plutocracy the the
wealthy take control
they strip away the rights of the poor
they enrich themselves and they laugh
about it they laugh in your face they
watch the city burn
and they're doing it i can only imagine
on purpose you can't have all these
riots
sweeping through the city and then bill
de blasio cheers for the protests
and across this country we see the same
thing in michigan we see in california
they march with the protesters they
cheer for it after they burn everything
down
kamala harris asks for donations for
rioters then she comes out what recently
saying oh the poor small business
what do you mean you have to bail out
the people who destroyed those
businesses
it's it's it's crazy to me that from the
start with cove in the lockdowns
15 days to slow the spread we all agreed
turned into what
what he just now the businesses are
are destroyed but you know you know it's
crazy you get a lot of businesses a lot
of perishables
food restaurants they were gone first
but what happened to the hard good
stores
all these stores that sold shirts
clothing branded gear
skateboards electronics well they were
fine right they could they could they
could stay
shut down until this all ended and then
the riots happened smashed all the
windows stole all the stuff
ripped these these businesses off that
finished them off then
kamala harris bails him out money many
of these leftist democrats bail these
people out cheer for it the politicians
the the governors the mayors march with
these people
then finally things are calming down
what happens well we get an election
they announce joe biden's the winner
they all come out dancing the streets
celebrating and it says you know
people of the world take notice
americans dance in the street
celebrating
and then a week you know not even a week
later three days later they're like
people
are start traveling for thanksgiving
shocking the world right
these are the news stories that we get
all of a sudden covert is back you know
they're telling me now i'm i'm here in
your maryland when i go back to new york
there's going to be people at the
bridges
and they're going to make me sign a
thing and take a cover test when the
sheriff pulls me over i'm going to tell
him to kiss my
fat behind and he can take my test when
he finishes licking it
that's what i'm going to tell them
nobody's going to tell me what to do you
know
governor mayor de blasio's daughter was
arrested for protesting too
yup she got out on a desk appearance
ticket which was like two hours later
me for the same thing that i did i had
to sit overnight in jail
you know his wife loses a billion two
dollars billion
1.25 billion dollars no questions asked
a couple of years ago about a year or
two ago we had a big police um
investigation and corruption a couple of
them were arrested
uh some uh personal bribed uh
uh police there was some private jewish
guy matter of fact from my community was
one of the leaders of this
of this criminal act very close to de
blasio and everybody was accusing and he
himself
testified on the stand against other
people and he testified that de blasio
got money
blasio wasn't touched wasn't arrested
not investigated
how don't worry about it when i get into
city council babies i'm going to
investigate i'm going to bring it back
he thinks he's going to get away with it
never he's gonna get away with it
so guys i am getting into city council i
don't know how
i don't know how i'm gonna do it but i'm
gonna try i'm here because
i'm not gonna sit back i'm not gonna
allow them
to and i'm going to repeat this over and
over to you until it gets through
everybody's head
you know i tell everybody watch my show
just enough history show wednesday night
like i keep repeating it
i want people to get it into their head
you can't hurt another person
it's it's a shame what they do to the
little people and and
and tim i i want you to come with me one
day in my neighborhood
to some of the homes that i visit they
don't have anything
i can't go to new york they'll
quarantine
we're going to trace all your family
members too but i i see people that when
we deliver food on a friday package in
my box
and you know the city was giving away
free food you should have seen it they
gave a box with a dirty bucket of yogurt
a a brown banana and some cereal this is
what you give to your family
my boxers have chicken i mean i can't do
more we do only 137 families but there's
other people that do more families we
have such
good volunteers you know america and i
love america i love america with
everything that my my my blood
runs red white and blue but again
america has its issues
we have a lot of sin and corruption and
and if you believe in god he would have
punished us he should have punished us
but the greatest thing of this country
the greatest why god won't touch us
why god has rewarded us we do the most
crested we call it in jewish the most we
charity the most genuine generosity in
this world
every every city every place where you
go there are charities from red cross
to doctors going freebies people giving
food that's why i tell people i tell it
to the young people
you think you have to do big things you
have to change the world and it's so
good when they do
i love when they do these young people
and i go to different
ethnic communities and i see these young
children trying and they're doing great
stuff
helping children go taking a kid and
study with them for an hour
go visit an old person once a week go
into the nursing home that's what i do i
have one lady i visit once a week
she's so happy when i get there for that
hour you wouldn't believe it
it's like a different world for me and
her bring a bottle of milk
to some old person that needs it or to a
young family
my box lasts my people till sunday and i
know
and i've been telling you the truth to
him and i'm embarrassed to tell you that
they
they they they scrounge and they skim a
little bit of food and
they have children some of these people
have three four kids so they try to make
it last until monday tuesday and i tell
them not to
it's wrong because we know you need a
real meal
you need a real breakfast you need a
piece of chicken you can't just have
a leg and think that it's good enough
you need to give the kid a sandwich
you know my kid came home from school i
paid my tuition i have private school
for my kids it's called yeshiva that's
what it's a regular school
and uh my kid came home one day and he
said pop
didn't have lunch so what does that mean
we paid for everything and my tuition is
for ten dollars a day for the kid and uh
i called up the school screaming at
halloween and they and they said well
you didn't pay
his lunch i said what are you talking
about i have the receipts oh we made a
mistake between
your kid and another kid i said so
another kid is not going to eat
i mean is that your answer to me so i i
went to the school and i spoke to the
parents of my kids class
and we saw that there were three kids
that couldn't afford the lunch program
and we put together the money it only
was like three dollars a day for all of
us parents whatever
and we made sure that those kids had the
food this is what other people do to
other people
it's unacceptable this great country
this
wonderful land we've we've built you
know after the revolution how
how we helped our neighbors build our
homes how we rebuilt america
yeah civil war was bad but again abram
lincoln stopped it
told everybody no no go home we're
buddies again
stop it and we built this nation back
piece by piece brick by brick we went to
world war
ii and we defended the rest of the world
not once
twice you know i want to tell you a
funny story not really funny for me it's
a serious story
i have a cousin called getzel schwartz
he passed away about two years ago
uh maybe a little bit more and i'm sure
you've seen the movie in glorious
bastards oh yeah
so it's a you think this movie is a fake
movie it's a true movie except for the
ending my
cousin lost 10 members of his family
wiped out in the war
killed and he and his father survived
they made it to america he couldn't
speak english but it was a bit tough you
know these big tough built european guys
and uh my mother made it to america with
ten of her
she only lost two my father lost uh uh
most of his family except for a sister
and another sister that couldn't have
children she was operated on
but getzel came alone and he came to
america right the beginning of the war
and what do you do with him he couldn't
speak english so he joined the army
and he was a jewish guy was a little
prejudicial back then
so they made him a paratrooper to jump
behind enemy lines i figured you know
the jew boy will be dead
no time this monster of a man jumped
mission
after mission after mission buying enemy
lines and i sat there as a little
six-year-old boy with my cousins the
girls
telling us stories how he got behind
nazi lines cutting their throats
stabbing them going back out
and we listened to his stories and they
were true because he had friends that
lived it
was a monster at 70 years old he was
still doing 100 push-ups in his
underwear
like an animal at the end of the war he
had medals like you never saw before
i've seen them and he found a sister
that survived he
he he got to the concentration camp
almost in time they killed her four days
before
wow he had a mental breakdown he went
into town he took his gun and started
shooting germans
wow and um they of course grabbed him
caught marshalled him but he's a hero
medals up to a zoo so they dishonorably
discharge them or honorably just tell
him he got a pension
and he left the army and he went home he
married a beautiful woman
and um what he did was he went with his
wife to israel
and it happened to be 1945 1946 when
again
israel became a state 1948 and the war
broke out
what do you think this crazy man did he
joined the israeli army wow
became a hero was a big time
hero he had a house in israel a house in
america two pensions back and forth good
looking man
and every time i saw him i i i couldn't
believe him when that movie and glory's
bastards came out i i said this is my
cousin
this is one of the boys i'm i'm confused
though uh you you're saying that you
you had family you you uh lost family in
the holocaust
yeah but you're a donald trump reporter
i was told by the left that trump is
literally hitler and he's a fascist oh
please
come on i mean i've seen i mean i'm from
new york city he has
people in in in low-income families that
he he lets live for free or
he helps out his charities everybody
messes up everybody's a businessman
everybody screws up everybody makes
mistakes he has got a team around him
you could talk to him about his
accounting
the man is the boss the boss the boss
puts out work people make mistakes
i like donald trump i believe he's an
honorable man he's done
more in one day of his life than i will
ever do in the next 10 years
you're you're from new york city yeah
brooklyn new york lived there your whole
life
all my life you were there uh in the 80s
when donald trump came in and started
taking the city back that's right i saw
him build that rink when he told koch
you're building a skating rink for six
years you can't finish it the man came
in in a few months
and finished it under budget wow stop it
guys
stop it i don't know what you're telling
me because the guy knows how to
uh pitch his product because he's a
great salesman wow i
am proud of him and when he ran for
president i couldn't believe it i said
why why would he do it and i'll tell you
why you're gonna tear him apart
i don't care he didn't care he did it
and this is why i believe he deserved a
second term
he took the ridicule i mean come on tim
russian collusion you believe
that the president of the united states
is a russian spy i mean did you actually
believe obama was a
a jihadist you know i mean you guys are
crazy
i mean we we're crazy sometimes the way
we think but
you actually for two years i'm watching
this he's a russian spy
we're going to impeach him because he
actually is russia
flynn cooperated with really it's a
shame what they did
and they wasted 40 million dollars this
guy muller
is an idiot i mean he doesn't deserve to
even have a license or to be even
respected
nadler my little fat i'm not going to
call him a name i know tim you're going
to kill me
but i have so many good names to say if
you let me say it and you'd make me
happy i'll give you a dollar
i have 10 bucks in my pocket you only
get a dollar i need nine bucks for those
tolls
right guys nine books anyways so um i
hate this little nadler man and he
he's did you ever see him when he got up
on the stage incompetent the way he
spoke the way he pitched his case
i mean it makes sense and then they
voted against party lines only one idiot
switched sides
romney i mean impossible and you knew
you weren't going to convict him
so you wasted another 10 15 million
dollars in the whole country's time
why again tim somebody's got to explain
it to me i don't understand there's a
there's a series now i guess it's called
empires of new york yeah have you seen
it i haven't seen it
it's it's it's like it's praise is
donald trump is that my understanding
talks about how he like rebuilt the city
and came in i saw a documentary a year
or so ago
that it was about i think it was an old
documentary it was about the 80s
and new york was crime infested the
trains were riddled with graffiti people
were scared
uh people were getting robbed and then
robbed you walk down williamsburg we
have a section now in williamsburg which
was very high priced now to buy a piece
of uh apartment is a thousand dollars a
square foot oh yeah when you walk there
as when i was a kid
if you weren't raped robbed stabbed
or you made it out alive really didn't
make a difference woman a man you are
lucky i had two brothers who um
had a warehouse there the father had to
wear us a little shoe company they used
to sneak in
and and all the the ladies of the
evening i want to say the bad word were
there
and it was like they told me they they
couldn't get for their building maybe a
few thousand dollars
when all this fancy high-priced stuff
went i mean it was so bad there
now they got millions of dollars they
sold it now to the yuppies oh yeah
but we've rebuilt the city donald trump
he's a businessman he has to make a
profit don't get me wrong i sometimes
don't agree with all his policies
but he gave jobs he gave you a chance to
make a living
you wanted to be a millionaire well
don't work for him but he gave you a
chance to at least to pay your bills
and that is what this gate great city
about somebody else can make money he
gives you an opportunity
take your opportunity if you don't like
it go away you know i have many guys
that i've worked for that
abused or knocked me or tried to cut my
prices
or didn't let me make a dollar i said
hey man i have a right to leave you or
have a right to take the job
i don't do business that way i make sure
both sides are correct
i like it that way i want i make a
little bit less let the other person
have a life
when uh when trump started running i was
actually i went and covered a bunch of
the trump rallies
and i went down i think one of the
things that definitely insulated me from
the trump derangement syndrome media
was first trump starts doing rallies i
go and i actually met trump supporters
talked a bunch of regular people
and then all of a sudden i hear from the
left that trump supporters are all crazy
violent rednecks and i'm like oh
no i met a lot of these people like
regular people and then the other
issue was that i went to trump tower and
i've been to trump tower
several times living in new york even
before trump was talking about running
or anything like that
and then you know you go to the ice
cream shop you go downstairs i've gone
to the restaurant you get a nice trump
steak or whatever
you bottled water and when trump was uh
you know getting
smeared and attacked in the media i went
to trump tower and i just you know went
to you know
you go down the escalator they got the
ice cream shop right there in new york
and i asked uh like so you guys know
trump and they're like yeah he comes
down every every so often and i was like
what do you think
cool dude no oh that guy's great they
tell me stories about how trump would
come down and drop a 100
bill in their tip jar all that kind of
stuff he's a good guy and so i'm like
i think he's got a mouth for sure i'm
sorry this is america
i'm allowed to say anything i want i
keep forgetting the first amendment the
second amendment the fifth amendment
we got a lot of amendments for a reason
he's allowed to say anything once except
if he's on youtube you can't i heard
that i got that
but do you know what's painted by the
way when you went to trump tower right
there in front of trump tower do you
ever see
those black lives matter now to paint
your sidewalk curb cut you know what
that is when you go up into your
driveway that little curb cut
to paint it yellow is illegal in the
city of new york
if you do it it's a thousand dollar fine
serious god forbid to paint your
sidewalk or
to block no parking mayor de blasio
painted black lives matter on an entire
block and not won two blocks
how do you do that and doing this
illegally during copy he's the mayor he
could do whatever he wants
so of course somebody in my community i
don't know who was running around bar
park or
painting yellow all lives matter for a
couple of days oh wow i wasn't sure he
was
they said he was a chubby guy with his
shirt on top but it wasn't me
it wasn't you i think it was linda my
wife thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time